Okay, real quick on the social media thing, guys.
Yeah.
Every week.
If you also want to post it, you just hit accept.
Cool.
We're going to send it to you, not via email anymore.
Right.
And if you want to post it, you just hit accept.
好吧，各位，关于社交媒体的事，我们简单说一下。对。每个星期。如果你也想发，点一下接受就行。行。我们会发给你，不再通过电子邮件了。没错。如果你想发，点一下接受就行。
Yeah.
And then it's just going to post right there.
Great.
And then is everybody like that?
Incredible.
You're cool with that, J.B?
Yeah, that sounds really fun.
Can we get to an old new smart list now?
对。然后它就会直接发出去。太好了。大家都是这样吗？太棒了。J.B，你觉得没问题吧？对，听起来挺有意思的。我们现在能聊聊一个老掉牙的新智能榜单吗？
Yeah.
Smart.
It's been a little bit.
How have you guys been?
What have you been up to?
We just saw each other on the weekend at Sean's play.
That's right.
That was fun, Sean.
对。智能。有一阵没聊了。你们最近怎么样？都在忙什么？我们周末刚在肖恩的戏剧演出现场见过面。没错。那挺有意思的，肖恩。
Congrats.
You're just such a beauty.
You're so.
That's very nice.
You're such a talent.
It's really.
Has it been, how many performances have you had since we saw you?
Three more than when you saw.
恭喜你。你真是太棒了。你太……这人真好。你太有才了。真的。自从我们上次见你之后，你有过，演了多少场了？比你看到的时候多三场。
But by the way, I have to say this.
Okay, go ahead.
First of all, the fact that you guys were great.
The fact that you guys came out, you flew out just to see the show.
meant the world to me.
I love you guys.
You're like, you are my family.
We love you.
不过话说回来，我得说这个。行，你说吧。首先，你们真的很棒。你们能特地飞来看演出，对我来说意义重大。我爱你们。你们就像，你们是我的家人。我们爱你。
And I love you too.
And it just was a huge deal to me
that you guys did that.
So thank you very, very much.
Oh, you kidding.
Well, was it not?
Because, you know, we were,
some people in the group had to evacuate their bowels
我也爱你们。你们能这么做，对我来说真的是一件大事。所以非常非常感谢你们。哦，别开玩笑了。难道不是吗？因为，你知道的，我们，组里有些人不得不排空肠胃
before the start of the show.
And so they wanted to use the restroom there.
And so you can.
What upstairs you mean?
Oh, yeah.
And so we're sitting there in the little like...
I would say it's just say they wanted to use the restroom.
Like, why doesn't it have to be grapies?
在演出开始前。所以他们想在那里的洗手间。你可以。你是说楼上？哦，对。然后我们就坐在那个小……我觉得应该说他们想去洗手间。为什么非得说得那么恶心？
And so we're sitting there waiting for the people with the weak bladder
and out walks Sean to talk to, I think, the director or something.
Yeah, yeah.
And you ran right into us.
And I saw in your face like, oh, oh, you saw someone before the show, kind of like a marriage.
That's right, that's right.
And so did we screw things up?
No, not at all.
然后我们就坐在那里，等着那些膀胱脆弱的人，肖恩走出来，好像是要跟导演什么的说话。对，对。你直接撞见我们了。我看到你脸上的表情，哦，哦，演出前见到熟人了，有点像结婚那种。没错，没错。那我们把事情搞砸了吗？没有，一点也没有。
not have people that you know in the audience?
No, no, I love it.
You knew we were all in a video.
Yeah, I knew. I knew, I knew all there, yeah.
But I didn't, yeah, I would have,
it was no big deal because I saw you,
and I wanted to talk to all of you, obviously,
because I hadn't seen you in so long.
观众里没有你认识的人吗？不，不，我喜欢这样。你知道我们都在视频里。对，我知道。我知道，我知道大家都在，对。但我没有，对，这没什么大不了的，因为我看到了你，我显然想和你们所有人说话，因为我好久没见你们了。
But then I was like, oh, you know what?
Let's just leave the facade up for a second,
and then I'll talk to them after.
Now, when you look out into the audience,
which you do a lot, because listener,
it is a one-man show,
and he is telling the audience's story,
Can you not see any of our faces?
但后来我想，哦，你知道吗？先维持一下假象，等下我再跟他们聊。现在，当你看向观众席时——你经常这样做，因为听众朋友们，这是一场独角戏，他在讲述观众的故事——你看不到我们的脸吗？
Can't see anybody.
I love it.
Yeah, because if I did, it'd make me nervous,
but the lights are so bright.
You can't see a foot in front of it.
Because you were looking right at me
for a lot of the show, and I thought,
oh, really?
什么都看不到。我喜欢这样。对，因为如果我看到的话，我会紧张，但灯光太刺眼了。连前面一英尺都看不清。因为演出中有很多时候你都在看着我，我想，哦，真的吗？
Make sure I don't make any funny faces
or throw them off because I don't want you to look, you know,
forgetting your lines.
I gotta say that's classic you that you thought he was looking at you.
Right, no, they're just looking right at me.
He chose me to look at.
No, yeah, no, I couldn't see anybody.
Well, like, when you, Jason, if you hear a song, a new song in the radio, are you thinking like, how do they, how do they know that about me?
得确保我不要做什么怪表情或者打扰到他，因为我不想让你看着，你知道的，忘了台词。我得说，你以为他在看着你，这真的很符合你的风格。对，不，他们就是看着我。他选了我来看。不，对，不，我谁也看不见。呃，就像你，杰森，如果你在收音机里听到一首歌，一首新歌，你会不会想，他们是怎么，他们是怎么知道我的事的？
They must be singing about me.
Yeah, exactly.
And how were we as an audience?
Fantastic, great show.
Yeah, really good show.
Do we laugh in all the right spots?
You did, and I told you the night before, I'm glad you didn't come to opening night because the lights went out.
Oh, yeah, you've got to hear, Sean, do you have any funny theater stories?
他们一定是在唱我。对，完全正确。那我们作为观众表现怎么样？棒极了，演出太棒了。对，非常棒的演出。我们在所有该笑的地方都笑了吗？笑啦，我前一天晚上就跟你说过，幸好你们没来看首演，因为灯光灭了。哦，对了，你得听听，肖恩，你有什么有趣的剧场故事吗？
I mean, yeah.
So the line that it went, I don't think it told you.
The line that it went out on was, because I play these characters,
but I also play the narrator,
so sometimes you just deliver straight lines that narrate.
And so one of the exposition lines that I narrated was,
we walked to the Hudson River.
And then I walked down stage, and every light went out.
我是说，有啊。所以灯光熄灭时的那句台词，我好像没跟你说过。灯光熄灭时我正在说的那句台词是——因为我扮演这些角色，但我也扮演旁白，所以有时你只是在念旁白台词。我念的一句背景台词是：我们走到了哈德逊河。然后我走下台，所有的灯都灭了。
Like, you couldn't see your hand in front of your face.
And I'm like, hey, give us a couple minutes.
I just said to the audience, and I walked off stage.
And it was like 10 minutes, which was a really long time.
A breaker, they had a breaker that went out or something.
They fixed it, and they go, okay, let's go back on.
And they go back and, of course, the audience claps.
Yay, they got the fix.
就像伸手不见五指一样。然后我说，嘿，给我们几分钟。我对观众说了这句话，然后走下了舞台。大约过了10分钟，时间真的很长。一个断路器，他们的断路器坏了什么的。他们修好了，然后说，好了，我们继续吧。他们走回去，当然，观众鼓掌了。耶，修好了。
The guy's back.
So I go, we walked to the Hudson River.
It was a really long walk.
Good for you, Shil.
Good for you.
And is there, so now are you feeling, I would feel,
the crush of the rest of the run in front of me
now that, like, opening night is over,
这家伙回来了。所以我说，我们走到了哈德逊河。那是一段很长的路。真有你的，希尔。真有你的。那么，现在，你感觉，我现在感觉到了剩余场次的压力，既然首演已经结束了，
and the reviews came in, and they were incredible.
And, like, can you still, as the kids say,
get it up for the rest of the show?
Yeah, for sure. I think it's easier now.
Okay.
Yeah, I think all that stuff where you're, it's tech and previews and rehearsal and press and opening night and then all that stuff.
It's so much pressure and stress and anxiety and all that.
Now it's just like, oh, I just have to do the show and come home, which is nice.
评论也出来了，而且棒极了。而且，就像孩子们说的，你还能为剩下的演出打起精神来吗？对，当然。我觉得现在更容易了。好吧。对，我觉得所有那些经历，技术彩排、预演、排练、宣传、首演以及所有这些事。压力、紧张和焦虑太大了，所有这些。现在就像是，哦，我只需要演完然后回家，这挺好的。
And you've got today off.
And today is off, yeah.
So what do you do today?
What have you loaded into today that you couldn't do on the previous six?
I'm hanging with you guys.
That's it all that.
And you're hanging with us.
And our special guest.
而且你今天休假。今天放假，对。那你今天打算干什么？你把今天安排了什么前六天没法做的事？我和你们一起鬼混。就这些，全都是这个。你在和我们一起鬼混。还有我们的特邀嘉宾。
Oh, that was really nice.
Our special guest, yeah.
And you'll like it because we can talk about all these things.
You can talk about theater.
I bet you she's got some theater stories
because she's done quite a bit of theater.
Oh.
And she's done quite a bit of film.
哦，那太好了。我们的特邀嘉宾，对。你会喜欢的，因为我们可以聊所有这些事情。你可以聊聊剧场。我敢打赌她有一些剧场故事，因为她演过不少剧场作品。哦。而且她拍过不少电影。
And some award-winning television.
Triple threat.
She's the daughter of two writer-directors.
Academy Award nominee.
Her mom was nominated for Academy Award, I believe.
both her parents are writer-directors.
She'd born in New York, grew up in L.A.
Her brother is an acclaimed actor.
还有一些获奖电视剧。三栖明星。她是两个编剧兼导演的女儿。奥斯卡奖提名者。我记得她妈妈曾获奥斯卡奖提名。她父母都是编剧兼导演。她出生在纽约，在洛杉矶长大。她哥哥是位广受赞誉的演员。
She has a new film coming out March 6.
Is this Maggie?
That has an amazing...
Is it?
Called The Bride starring Jesse Buckley, Christian Bill.
It's Maggie Gillen.
Yes, Shawnee?
Shelly got it.
她有一部新电影将于3月6日上映。这是玛姬吗？那部有着惊人……是吗？叫《科学怪新娘》，由杰西·巴克利、克里斯蒂安·贝尔主演。是玛姬·吉伦哈尔。对，肖妮？雪莉猜对了。
We have to establish a gift or a prize for whoever gets it.
I know.
That's pretty good at it.
Hi, Maggie.
How about that?
Hi, guys.
Hi.
我们得为猜对的人准备一份礼物或奖品。我知道。她猜得挺准。嗨，玛姬。怎么样？嗨，大家。嗨。嗨。
Well, I gotta say that trailer at The Bride looks effing, fantastic.
Oh my God.
I can't wait to see it.
Thank you.
Cannot wait.
I can't wait either.
I mean, this, talk about a, just an absolutely star-studded cast.
It's unbelievable, Maggie.
好吧，我得说《科学怪新娘》那个预告片看起来真是太棒了。天哪。我迫不及待想看了。谢谢。迫不及待。我也迫不及待。我是说，这，可以说是全明星阵容了。真是难以置信，玛姬。
Well, believable.
I mean, believable.
I mean incredible director.
Why would they want to, you know.
I don't mean unbelievable in that way.
I mean, unbelievable how great it is.
That's what I mean.
嗯，难以置信。我是说难以置信。我是说导演太棒了。他们为什么会想要，你知道的。我不是那个意思。我不是那个意思。我是说，好得难以置信。我是这个意思。
Truly.
Yeah, amazing actors.
Amazing.
I know.
Oh, my God.
All right.
So when do we get to see this movie?
And we're going to talk about the rest of your career.
真的。对，演员太棒了。太棒了。我知道。哦，天哪。好吧。那我们什么时候能看到这部电影？我们还要聊聊你的演艺生涯。
But when do we get to see this movie?
When's it come out?
March 6th.
So it's probably out now.
The bride.
Yeah.
So, all right, Maggie.
但是我们什么时候能看到这部电影？什么时候上映？3月6日。3月6日。所以现在可能已经上映了。新娘。对，好吧，玛姬。
Maggie, Joie.
This is so nice.
Hi, guys.
Are you loving directing more than acting?
I am, yeah.
Yeah, right.
Are you more than acting?
Tell me why.
玛姬，乔伊。太好了。嗨，大家。你是不是比当演员更喜欢当导演？是的，确实。对，没错。比当演员更喜欢吗？告诉我为什么。
I mean, it's like really you are in charge.
of everything, which then means that you can make space for everyone else to offer what they want,
express what they want.
You're not, you know, like when you're an actor and you're like, okay, I need to make sure
that I just create the space for myself to get out the couple of things that are the most
important things to me in case nobody lets me.
You know that feeling?
Like, you know, you're just trying to figure out, like, how to just protect your little
我是说，这就像是你真正掌握着一切。一切的主动权，这意味着你可以为其他人腾出空间，让他们表达他们想要的，展现他们想要的。你不用，你知道的，就像当你是一个演员时，你会想，好吧，我需要确保自己能创造空间，把对我来说最重要的一些事情表达出来，以防没人让我这样做。你懂那种感觉吗？就像，你知道，你只是在想方设法保护你那一点点
thing, which is the reason why you came to do it.
When you're the director, you don't have to do that, first of all.
And also, you don't have to make other people do that.
You can just make it okay for them to feel free.
So you must have, I mean, obviously, as I pointed out,
that you come by quite honestly, both your parents are directors and writers.
And so did you, but then you've had such an acclaimed acting career
before you directed your first piece.
小东西，也就是你来做这件事的原因。当你成为导演时，首先，你不需要那样做。而且，你也不需要让其他人那样做。你只需让他们感到自由即可。所以你一定，我是说，很明显，正如我所指出的，你这绝对是家学渊源，你的父母都是导演和编剧。所以，在执导你的第一部作品之前，你是不是已经有了这样出色的演艺生涯？
But did you know in the back of your mind
because it was just so there
that that was your ultimate destination?
Like, was acting a way of sort of getting there?
I mean, I...
First of all, yes, my dad was a director growing up.
My mom was a writer.
She did direct a film,
但你在潜意识里是否早就知道，因为这一切就摆在那里，那才是你的最终归宿？也就是说，演戏是通往那个目标的一种方式吗？我是说，我……首先，是的，我爸爸在我成长过程中是一名导演。我妈妈是一名作家。她确实导演过一部电影，
but it wasn't until, I think she was 70.
You know, it was like a total wild departure.
That's cool.
For her.
I think she might be the...
one of the only people to direct their first film as a grandmother.
That's cool.
I told your brother when he was on that I had dinner with your mom once
但直到，我想她当时70岁。你知道的，这完全是一个疯狂的转变。太酷了。对她而言。我想她可能是……作为祖母执导自己第一部电影的仅有几人之一。太酷了。我曾对你哥哥说过，有一次我和你妈妈吃过晚饭，
years and years and years ago,
and I was talking to her about writing.
And it's the first time I ever heard anybody say
the hardest part is starting about writing.
And I was like, oh, that blew my mind because I was like,
I tried to.
I was like, I couldn't do it.
It's like exercising.
那是好多年好多年以前的事了，当时我和她聊起写作。那是我第一次听到有人说写作最难的部分是开始。当时我想，哦，这让我大开眼界，因为我想，我试过。我想，我做不到。这就像锻炼身体。
Just get your clothes on.
If you have your exercise clothes on and you don't exercise,
then you really fucked up.
Sean, so exercising is this thing that people...
You break the sweat.
This is not for Tracy.
This is for Sean.
But you were asking me if I always wanted to be a director.
把衣服穿上就行。如果你穿好了运动服却不运动，那你可就真搞砸了。肖恩，锻炼身体就是那种人们……你会流汗。这不是针对特雷西的。这是针对肖恩的。但你刚才问我是否一直想当导演。
I don't think so.
I think I, to be honest, I don't even...
I didn't even allow myself to fantasize or imagine that it was a possibility for a long time.
I mean, there weren't any other women doing it.
I mean, there were, but I wasn't cool enough to know about.
like Agnes Varda when I was in high school, you know?
I mean, I really, the people who were really doing great stuff on film were actresses,
at least from my perspective, and I had, I looked up to so many people who were, you know,
我不这么觉得。我觉得，老实说，我甚至……很长一段时间里，我甚至都不允许自己去幻想或想象那是一种可能。我是说，没有其他女性在做这件事。我是说，其实是有的，但我当时还不够酷，不知道像是阿涅斯·瓦尔达，在我上高中的时候，你知道吗？我是说，真正拍出伟大电影的人其实是女演员，至少从我的角度来看是这样，我曾仰慕过许多这样的人，你知道的，
totally expressing themselves and being incredible, but I didn't see a lot of directors.
And then I played a director on TV.
I mean, I played a porn director on The Deuce.
Yes, right.
But I think that was actually sort of part of just imagining, fantasizing.
It, like, allowed me to imagine it.
So what was the first, I'm trying to think the first thing that you directed?
The Lost Daughter.
她们完全在表达自我，表现得不可思议，但我没看到很多女导演。后来我在电视里扮演了一个导演。我是说，我在《堕落街传奇》里扮演了一个色情片导演。是的，没错。但我想那其实正是想象、幻想的一部分。它让我能够去想象这种可能。所以，我想想，你执导的第一部作品是什么？《暗处的女儿》。
It was the Lost Daughter.
Yeah.
Which was super well received.
And so then, but that was only, that was like five years ago, maybe, the Lost Daughter, right?
Four years ago?
Four or five years ago?
Four or five years ago, yeah.
So, but was there any time before,
是《暗处的女儿》。对。这部作品反响极好。然后，但那也只是，大约是五年前吧，《暗处的女儿》，对吧？四年前？四五年前？四五年前，对。所以，但在那之前有什么时候，
was that really the first time that you allowed yourself
to kind of contemplate doing it?
You must have.
I spent, I mean, you guys must know what I mean.
Like, I sort of just was talking about this,
like that feeling of like how, you know,
it's almost like when you're a kid
and you're like, if I had this job,
那真的是你第一次允许自己去考虑做导演吗？你肯定想过。我花了很多时间，我是说，你们一定明白我的意思。就像我刚才说的那种感觉，你知道，这有点像当你还是个孩子的时候，你会想，如果我有这份工作，
I would never speak to someone like this.
Or I would never make them twist themselves into a pretzel
to get this tiny thing, like cut this line or whatever.
And so I guess I imagined it in that level
Or even with writing
I would cut chunks of dialogue
Or just kind of sneakily move a line
But no, I think really I just kind of went
我绝不会对别人这样说话。或者我绝不会为了得到这点小事而让他们绞尽脑汁，比如删掉这句台词什么的。所以我想我在那个层面上想象过。甚至在写作时，我也会删掉大段的对话，或者偷偷挪动一句台词。但我觉得实际上我只是觉得
All right, I'm going to try this
I'm going to, I did it, I wrote Lost Daughter also
And each step I thought, okay, I'm just going to take this step
And we'll see how it feels
And then once I started doing it, I think I immediately just went
this is a way better job for me.
Yeah. Yeah. And what was that
when you direct your first directing gig,
好吧，我要试试这个。我要去，我做了，我也写了《暗处的女儿》。每走一步我都想，好吧，我就迈出这一步，看看感觉怎么样。然后一旦我开始做这件事，我想我立刻就觉得这对我来说是一份好得多的工作。对。对。当你第一次当导演时，
what was the thing
that you were overwhelmed with or scared
about the most?
Before, before I did it?
Like as you were prepping the film,
what was the most thing you were scared about?
It's funny. I was so much
scarter about making the bride
最让你不知所措或感到害怕的是什么？在你做之前？就像你在筹备电影时，最让你害怕的是什么？这很有趣。我筹备《科学怪新娘》时感到的恐惧，
than I ever was about making the lost daughter.
I was scared, I was. But I think in some ways
I didn't even know
what I was walking into.
I mean, that said, I'd been on so many sets.
I think about directors who are really first-time directors
who don't know how to read a call sheet,
you know, who don't know what the rhythm of a day feels like,
远超过我筹备《暗处的女儿》时的恐惧。我很害怕，真的。但从某种程度上说，我甚至不知道自己即将面对什么。我是说，话虽如此，我去过那么多片场。我想起那些第一次当导演的导演，他们甚至不知道怎么看通告单，你知道吗，他们不知道一天的节奏是怎样的，
who, that must be really, really scary.
Yeah, so when you're doing the bride,
like you kind of, now you know, so you've had the experience, right?
So then you have that anticipation of like,
shit, now I know where some of the pitfalls are.
How's that going to go?
How's that emergency going to go?
But even more than that, I think with the bride, I actually was terrified before I started.
对他们来说，那一定非常非常可怕。所以当你拍《科学怪新娘》时，你有点像，现在你知道了，所以你有了经验，对吧？然后你就会有那种期待，糟糕，现在我知道有些陷阱在哪里了。这会怎么样？那个紧急情况会怎么处理？但不仅如此，我觉得在拍《科学怪新娘》之前，我其实吓坏了。
I was like, I wrote the script.
It came out very, not easily, obviously.
Writing is so hard, but there wasn't ease to it.
And then I was scared.
I was really scared.
The bride was number two, the second film.
Yeah.
And it's a significant jump forward as far as budget and scope.
我想，我写了剧本。它的诞生非常，当然也不是轻而易举。写作太难了，但它有一种顺畅感。然后我很害怕。我是真的很害怕。《科学怪新娘》是第二部，第二部电影。对。而且在预算和规模上是一个巨大的飞跃。
and just basic responsibility,
a big piece of Hollywood business too
and big huge stars.
And yeah, that must have been, yeah, sobering to say the least.
Yeah, I mean, it's interesting.
On set, even though it was, as you say,
like the scope was just much bigger,
it felt very similar to The Lost Daughter
还有基本的责任，这也是好莱坞的一大块业务，还有很多大明星。是的，这肯定，让人清醒，至少可以说。是的，我是说，这很有趣。在片场，尽管正如你所说，规模大得多，但感觉和《暗处的女儿》非常相似。
in terms of just working, workflow, how we did it.
And I didn't know that it would,
and I think that's part of why I was scared.
But once we got working, it was the same.
And yet, actually, maybe even easier in some ways
because the heads of every department were incredible.
Yeah.
You know, I mean, in Greece...
从实际工作、工作流程和我们的做法来看。我当时不知道会是这样，我想这也是我害怕的部分原因。但一旦开始工作，情况就都一样了。而且在某些方面甚至更容易，因为每个部门的负责人都是难以置信的优秀。是的。你知道的，我的意思是，在希腊……
And you had a longer schedule, too, right?
We had a longer schedule.
I mean, like, maybe even twice as long.
I shot...
Not quite twice as long, but I shot the last daughter in 2016.
So it was really quick.
Wow.
That's fast.
而且你们的拍摄周期也更长，对吧？我们的拍摄周期更长。我的意思是，可能甚至长了一倍。我拍过……差不多长了一倍，我在2016年拍摄了《暗处的女儿》。所以节奏非常快。哇。那真快。
But there was so much story and there was so much to do.
It wasn't like we were hanging out eating sushi.
We were really working on the bride.
We were like, you know, down to the minute every day.
But I do think also like the bigger scope and the excellent, excellent crew,
I mean, had a great crew in Greece on The Lost Daughter,
but they don't have a props master, for instance.
They don't have someone who takes care of props.
但里面有那么多的故事，有那么多事情要做。我们可不是在那里闲逛吃寿司。我们真的是在为《新娘》努力。我们每天都精确到每一分钟。但我确实也认为，更大的规模和优秀至极的剧组——我的意思是，《暗处的女儿》在希腊有一个很棒的剧组，但他们没有道具主管，比如说。他们没有专门照顾道具的人。
So I had a very important doll in that movie.
I don't know if you guys saw it.
And we had one doll.
And it was like, you know, it's just, you know,
we're sort of scrapping it together, like, as best we can.
And we were not doing that on The Bride.
We had great people.
As an actor, as a great actor yourself,
所以在那个电影里我有一个非常重要的娃娃。我不知道你们有没有看过。我们只有一个娃娃。那感觉就像是，你知道的，我们只能尽我们所能地凑合着拼凑起来。但在《新娘》我们可没有那样做。我们有很棒的人。作为一名演员，作为一个伟大的演员，
how, I'm assuming that your knowledge of being an actor,
affects the way in which you direct actors.
And are you, do you find yourself directing every actor as if that actor is you?
Or are you intuitive and you figure out a different way to direct different actors based on what you assume their needs are?
You know?
That's such an interesting question, actually.
Thank you.
When I started The Lost Daughter, I started with, I don't know,
我假设你作为演员的经验会影响你指导演员的方式。你会发现自己在指导每个演员时都把对方当成你自己吗？还是说你会凭直觉，根据你对他们需求的假设，想出不同的方式来指导不同的演员？你知道吗？这其实是一个非常有趣的问题。谢谢。当我开始拍《暗处的女儿》时，我从，我不知道，
eight days with Jesse Buckley.
Pretty much, Jesse is the center
of pretty much every scene.
And I spoke to Jesse the way I would speak to myself.
Like the way I sort of wished someone would speak to me, you know?
And with Jesse, it just went in like water.
And then I tried to talk to Olivia Coleman that way.
And she was like, what the fuck are you talking about?
跟杰西·巴克利一起拍了八天。基本上，杰西是几乎每一个场景的中心。我跟杰西说话的方式就是我会跟自己说话的方式。就像我某种程度上希望别人跟我说话的方式，你知道吗？对杰西来说，这话就像水一样直接流进去了。然后我试图用那种方式跟奥利维亚·科尔曼说话。结果她说，你在说什么鬼话？
You know?
She was like, what?
And I really quickly, like, on the job, had to really
realize, oh, right, no, of course.
Like, I can't talk to my husband the way I talk to Jesse either.
He's also like, fuck off, what?
You know, so that was such a pleasure to me, actually.
That was actually, I would say, one of my absolute favorite things about the last daughter was learning, oh, oh, what language is it with this person?
你知道吗？她当时就像是，什么？我非常快地，在工作中就意识到，哦，对了，不，当然。就像我也不能用跟杰西说话的方式跟我丈夫说话一样。他也会说，滚开，什么？你知道的，所以对我来说这其实是一种巨大的乐趣。那实际上，我要说是关于《暗处的女儿》我最绝对最喜欢的事情之一，就是去学习，哦，哦，跟这个人究竟该用什么语言？
And then bringing that to the bride.
I mean, like, how does Penelope Cruz want to be talked to versus an epistem?
Benning.
Like, Annette, I realized I would get so excited by what she was doing.
I would come to her with like three notes on top of each other.
And she just would not have it.
She wanted one in a time.
And made that very clear to me.
然后把这套方法带到《新娘》中。我的意思是，佩内洛普·克鲁兹希望别人怎么跟她说话，安妮特·贝宁又希望怎么被对待？比如安妮特，我意识到她所做的事情会让我感到无比兴奋。我会带着好几个叠加在一起的建议去找她。而她根本不接受。她希望一次只听一个。并且把这一点对我说得很清楚。
Whereas, like, you know, Jesse just wants to sort of take it all in and whatever sticks,
and yeah, Peter just like, well.
But that's a process that you learn as you go, right?
Like it's something like you have to, like that first day, that first word,
week you're
it's the personalities
and you're trying to figure out
what that rhythm was like Jay
然而，你知道的，杰西只是想把所有东西都吸收进去，能听进去多少是多少，然后，是的，皮特只是……但这是一个边做边学的过程，对吧？就像你必须经历的那样，第一天，第一周，你要去摸索性格，并试图弄清楚那种节奏是什么样的，就像杰伊
what you were kind of saying like
how you have to
it's not that you're tailoring it but it's
you have to have a certain amount of
EQ to be a really good
director I think
the really good ones have that understanding
as you pointed out to go oh this person
你刚才说的那种，你必须要——这倒不是说你在量身定制，而是你必须具备一定的情商才能成为一个真正优秀的导演。我认为真正优秀的导演都有那种理解力，正如你所指出的，去发现，哦，这个人
you have to kind of read the room
right a hundred percent
I think you do tailor it to each person
like and that interaction
is one of my
favorite things.
And sometimes there's friction, too.
Like, not, not, but it's only natural that there will be moments.
你必须得看懂现场的氛围，对吧？百分之百。我认为你确实会为每个人进行量身定制，而这种互动是我最喜欢的事情之一。有时候也会有摩擦。不是说——但是会有这种时刻是再自然不过的了。
Yeah.
We've all had them where somebody gives you a note or something, you go like, hey, you know,
and you're just trying to, and then, and sometimes it's necessary.
Or sometimes you need friction in order to do whatever it is you need to do, and the director
just has to just deal with that.
Like, I remember, I won't say who, just so that I'm, because I love him, but there was an
actor who yelled at me on The Lost Daughter, and none of us had been yelling at each other.
Like, we were just, it was all, we were all in love.
对。我们都遇到过这种情况，当某人给你提意见或者别的什么时，你会觉得，嘿，你知道的，你只是在努力去沟通，然后有时候这是必要的。或者有时你需要摩擦来完成你需要做的任何事情，而导演必须去处理它。比如，我记得——为了保护他我就不说名字了，因为我爱他——在《暗处的女儿》里有个演员冲我大喊大叫，而我们之前谁都没有对彼此大喊大叫过。我们所有人之间，都是充满了爱意的。
And I was sort of stunned for a second.
And then I was like, oh, no, no, no, I've been him.
I know, I get it.
Okay, he just needs to, like, crack something a little bit.
Just take it.
Just take the smack and just keep going.
That's your job.
Like, a little taste of your own medicine.
我当时愣了一秒钟。然后我就想，哦，不，不，不，我以前也是他那样。我懂，我明白。好吧，他只是需要，把某些紧绷的东西稍微打破一点。接着受着。挨这一下然后继续。这就是你的工作。就当是尝尝自己平时对待别人的滋味吧。
Keep going.
He's kind of just in character.
And just trying to, like, break something.
Like just make something alive happen.
You know, that's interesting you say that because and it is when you're in such an extreme
sort of creative environment and sometimes, as you say, sometimes that needs to happen.
And I think that there are plenty of examples of people who are especially historically
poorly behaved who are really terrible to people and stuff.
继续。他其实只是在戏里。只是试图去打破某种东西。让某种有生命力的东西发生。你知道，你这么说很有意思，因为当你处于那种极端密闭的创作环境中时，有时正如你所说，那种情况就是会发生。而且我认为有很多例子表明，那些特别是在历史上表现糟糕的人，对别人非常恶劣之类的事情。
But there are, there also is an area where there has to be that sort of friction where people do
and people will say like, oh, that's just Hollywood.
People are badly behaved.
Like, no, this is like a really intense creative environment
that also you're dealing with where the currency is emotion
and people and human beings.
And there's going to be that.
And sometimes that exists, right?
但也有这样一个领域，必须存在那种摩擦，人们会这样做，人们会说，哦，那只是好莱坞。人们表现得很糟糕。不，这实际上是一个非常激烈的创作环境，同时你还要处理以情感、人和人类为流通货币的事情。这种摩擦是会存在的。有时候它就是会存在，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
I think acting, having done it,
listen, I think directing is a harder job.
No question.
But I think there's something about acting
that is so, so precious, like beyond what anyone's doing, so vulnerable, so special.
You know, I really do.
I just think, like, you know.
对，对。我觉得表演，既然我自己做过，听着，我认为导演是一份更难的工作。毫无疑问。但我觉得表演有一种非常非常珍贵的东西，超越了任何人的所作所为，它是那么脆弱，那么特别。你知道的，我真的是这么想的。我只是觉得，你知道的。
You're putting yourself out there to be judged over and over and over again.
Well, I was listening to them talking about your play, a one man, play, man, I, that's hardcore.
Yeah, so that's exhausting.
Especially staring at Jason the whole time, evident.
Yeah, exactly.
I tried not to blank, Shawnee.
I'm so sorry.
And we will be right back.
你把自己置于聚光灯下去一遍又一遍地接受评判。好吧，我刚才听他们在谈论你的独角戏，天哪，那太硬核了。对，所以那太消耗体力了。尤其是还得一直盯着杰森看，显然。对，没错。我尽量不眨眼，肖妮。真是不好意思。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
So when you talk about, like, part of the actor's sort of high wire act and vulnerability
is showing kind of what your version of this character is.
And oftentimes, this is for Tracy out there,
oftentimes an actor will get a part through an audition process.
And through that audition process, you basically show the director,
Well, here's my version of the character.
And if you want this version, go ahead and hire me.
现在回到节目中。所以当你在谈论——演员那种高空走钢丝般的表演和脆弱性的一部分，就是展示你对这个角色的理解版本。通常情况下，对于特拉西这样的人来说，演员会通过试镜流程获得一个角色。通过那个试镜流程，你基本上是在向导演展示，好吧，这就是我版本的角色。如果你想要这个版本，那就雇我吧。
And then when I show up on the set,
you'll know exactly what's coming.
When you're dealing with big stars like the kind Maggie has in this film,
they're not auditioning.
So the first time Maggie's getting to see their version of these characters
is kind of through the rehearsal process,
which is kind of like a week or two out
and just kind of around a table reading.
然后当我出现在片场时，你就会完全知道会发生什么。当你面对像玛吉这部电影里那种大明星时，他们不需要试镜。所以玛吉第一次看到他们对这些角色的演绎版本，是通过排练过程，也就是开拍前一周左右，大家围坐在一起读剧本的时候。
But really mostly it's on set.
And it's kind of too late to make changes.
So my question, Maggie, is,
especially since you've written this thing too,
how do you rate your ability to be flexible,
to be nimble to the inevitably different version of these characters
than you've always imagined in your head?
And how do you not assess like sort of a false negative
但实际上大部分还是在片场。那时候要做改动已经有点太迟了。所以我的问题是，玛吉，特别是既然这个东西也是你写的，你如何评价自己保持灵活应变的的能力？面对那些跟你脑海中一直想象的截然不同的角色版本时，你如何做到随机应变？你又如何避免给那场表演打上，
on that performance just simply because it's different
than what you've imagined?
Because the audience hasn't read the script.
They don't have any preconceived notion.
So they're going to take what they get.
And the actor is kind of approaching their performance with that assumption.
And they just hope the director slash writer will give the same level of freedom and acceptance to that version of the character.
Did you find yourself comfortable with that?
一种虚假的差评，仅仅因为它和你想象的不一样？因为观众并没有读过剧本。他们没有任何先入为主的概念。所以他们看到什么就会接受什么。而演员在进行表演时也是基于这种假设。他们只是希望导演兼编剧能对他们那个版本的角色给予同等程度的自由和接受。你发现自己能适应这种状态吗？
Because that's hard.
By the way, that's a really good question.
The first 30 seconds of that was a great question.
The last four minutes were insane.
We'll trim it.
I was actually riveted by everything.
I was too.
I was like, yeah, Jason, that is because I hate to admit.
因为那很难。顺便说一句，那真的是个好问题。前30秒是个极好的问题。最后四分钟简直疯了。我们会把它剪掉的。我其实对这一切都听得入迷了。我也是。我当时想，没错，杰森，就是这样，因为我不愿承认。
It's a great question.
I was like, yes, I always wanted to know that.
Yeah.
Well, this is like one of the reasons why I became a director, although we can talk about some of the other ones, but I think I've so often been the person who came to set with just a different take on something, not just to be contrarian or be different, but because it's me that's making it.
And I'm different than what the director imagined when they were alone in their room.
Right.
And I have so many.
times thought, don't you want my mind too?
这是一个很好的问题。我当时想，对啊，我一直都想知道这个。嗯，好吧，这也是我成为导演的原因之一，虽然我们也可以谈谈其他原因，但我认为我经常是那个带着对某事完全不同的看法来到片场的人，不仅仅是为了唱反调或与众不同，而是因为我是那个在创作它的人。我跟导演独自在房间里构思时想象的样子是不一样的。对吧。而且我经常想，难道你不想拥有我的想法吗？
Like, don't you want, like, my heart to?
I don't want to be just a puppet.
Like, yeah, isn't it going to be a better movie if, like, all of us actors and the DP
and the designer, you know, all put ourselves into it?
And then, yes, as the director, I mean, I would say this.
I would say, yes, I feel very strongly that I'm trying not to push actors into doing
something that I imagined when I was all by myself.
and I don't do that
就像，难道你不想拥有我的心吗？我不想只做一个木偶。就像，对啊，如果我们这些演员、摄影指导和美术设计，你知道的，都把自己的心血倾注进去，电影不是会更好吗？然后，是的，作为导演，我是这样认为的。我会说，是的，我强烈地认为，我尽量不把演员推向我一个人独处时想象的方向去，而且我不会那样做
because it's just not my taste
it's just not what I like from them, you know?
Which means that they surprise me all the time.
That said, I think it's my job
if we're trying to walk a tightrope
across the two hours of this movie,
it's my job to both allow them sometimes,
okay, look, we did a take
因为那不是我的品味，那不是我从他们身上希望看到的，你知道吗？这意味着他们总是能给我带来惊喜。话虽如此，我认为如果我们要在这部电影的两个小时里如履薄冰，我的职责既是偶尔允许他们——好吧，听着，我们拍了一条
where the whole second half of that
you were falling off the tightrope.
I mean, I'm not going to say that to them,
but I'm not going to use it, you know?
And yet, like, what it did was it got us to the next take
where there was a laser beam focus or whatever.
You know, I mean, I think it's my job to then assess it
and take care of it and really protect the things that are really special and beautiful.
那条的后半部分你整个人都在如履薄冰般摇摇欲坠。我的意思是，我不会对他们这么说，但我不会采用那一条，你知道吗？然而，这么做的效果是，它把我们带到了下一条，在那里有一种激光般集中的专注力什么的。你知道的，我的意思是，我认为我的职责是去评估它、处理它，并真正保护那些真正特别和美好的东西。
I mean, I think you can watch a movie.
You can, let me say this.
I think there's lots of really good actors.
And I think there's a handful of really brilliant ones.
And like you guys said, a lot of them are.
in my movie.
And so how do you make space
for those really brilliant actors
我的意思是，我认为你可以看一部电影。你可以，让我这么说吧。我认为有很多非常优秀的演员。而且我认为有少数几个是极其出色的。就像你们说的，其中很多都在我的电影里。所以，你如何为那些真正出色的演员腾出空间
to not act like they're learning something
or changing on film,
but actually learn something
or make a change on film?
That's the most exciting thing for me to watch.
I think that's a really great point that you bring up to this idea
of like, of sort of walking that tightrope
and maybe there's part of a take where they don't,
让他们看起来不像是为了拍戏而在学习或改变，而是真正在银幕上学到东西或发生改变？对我来说，看这个是最令人兴奋的。我认为你提出的这个观点非常好，关于那种如履薄冰的感觉，也许某一条里他们没有做到，
and you don't bring it up.
it allows you to get to that other place.
And I think that in that process,
if you can allow, certainly for me, I know,
if you can feel safe enough that there are no wrong answers
and that it's okay to do that,
then that's where you can really find that growth.
You can really find that other gear by allowing us.
而你没有提出来。这能让你到达另一个境界。我认为在这个过程中，如果你能允许——对我来说肯定是的——如果你能感到足够安全，觉得没有错误的答案，这样做是可以的，那么这正是你能真正找到成长的地方。通过允许我们，你真的能找到那种不同的状态。
Because if you're worried that you're getting it,
you're going to get it wrong or you're not doing it right.
You're fucked.
Because in the other gear, there aren't any wrong answers.
Like when you get in.
to that other gear.
It's all good.
What about,
因为如果你担心自己会弄砸，或者你觉得做得不对。你就完蛋了。因为在另一种状态下，没有错误的答案。就像当你进入那种状态时。一切都很好。话说回来，
how,
dumb,
dumb question,
how did you think
of doing this movie,
the bride,
where did the idea
come from?
怎么说，这是一个有点蠢的问题，你是怎么想到拍这部电影《科学怪人的新娘》的，这个想法是从哪里来的？
Why did you want to do it?
And isn't it kind of cool
that Frankenstein
just came out
and then the bride?
I mean, it's so cool.
Holy shit,
you're right,
你为什么想拍它？而且，弗兰肯斯坦刚刚上映，紧接着又是《新娘》，这不是很酷吗？我的意思是，太酷了。靠，你说得对，
that was a dumb,
dumb,
question.
You're so right.
I just think that's so cool
that that's all happening
at the same time.
Me too.
那真是一个有点蠢的问题。你说得太对了。我只是觉得这些都在同一时间发生真是太酷了。我也是。
You must have been aware
of that other movie.
Guillermo's movie,
yeah.
And I, I, well, I'll answer the first part of the question first, which is I was at a party.
I was thinking about what I wanted to do.
You know, I was kind of knocking things around in my mind, just sort of more just thinking about what was on the edges of my mind.
It's kind of hard to explain, I guess, but even with acting, I don't know if you guys relate to this at all.
你当时肯定知道那部电影。吉尔莫的电影，对吧。我，我，好吧，我先回答问题的第一个部分，那就是我在一个派对上。我在想我想做什么。你知道的，我当时在脑子里琢磨各种事情，更确切地说，只是在思考我脑海边缘的东西。这有点难解释，我想，甚至对于表演来说，我不知道你们是否能对此产生共鸣。
But like the things that appeal to me are usually the things that are like right on the edge of what I've been thinking about.
And then the making of the movie can be a way of kind of getting into some dangerous territory about what you don't know, you know.
So I was thinking about, I don't know, what do I want to do next?
And I saw this guy with a tattoo of the bride of Frankenstein on his entire forearm.
You know, the Elsa, Lancaster, electricity hair.
Yeah.
And I was like, oh, yeah, wait, what is that?
It's the bride of Frankenstein, but who is she, you know?
但吸引我的事情通常都是那些正好处于我一直在思考的边缘的事情。然后制作电影的过程可以成为一种方式，让你进入一些关于你所未知事物的危险领域，你知道的。所以我当时在想，我不知道，我接下来想做什么？然后我看到这个人整个前臂上纹着《科学怪人的新娘》的纹身。你知道的，埃尔莎·兰开斯特那种触电般的发型。对，然后我就想，哦，对，等等，那是什么？那是科学怪人的新娘，但她是谁呢，你知道吗？
And I went back to my hotel.
I was in L.A. at the time.
And I looked her up online.
And I was like, yeah, she's so, like...
Badass.
Yeah, so badass. Exactly.
Then I watched the movie, which I had never seen.
And she's in it for two minutes.
然后我回到了酒店。我当时在洛杉矶。我在网上查了查她。然后我就想，天哪，她太……太飒了。对，太飒了。没错。然后我看了这部电影，我以前从未看过。她在里面只出现了两分钟。
And she doesn't speak at all.
And I started to think about this idea of the bride
of Frankenstein.
And, you know, well, then I went and read the book,
which I had also never read.
And Frankenstein is so lovely in the book.
I mean, he does murder people and, you know,
he's...
而且她一句话也没说。我开始思考科学怪人的新娘这个概念。然后，我去读了这本书，我也从来没读过。书中的弗兰肯斯坦是那么可爱。我是说，他的确杀过人，而且，你知道的，他……
It's going to happen.
It's very light.
We all have a bad day.
No, but there is an aspect of exactly that,
where you read it and you're like,
wait, I also feel lots of rage and violence sometimes.
I don't murder people, but he's so huge.
human. Like, he's so vulnerable. He's so lonely in the book. He's also super smart. He literally
这总是会发生的。很轻松嘛。我们都会有糟糕的一天。不，但确实有这样一个方面，当你读到它时，你会想，等等，有时候我也会感到很多愤怒和暴力。我没有杀人，但他太有人情味了。就像，他太脆弱了。他在书中是那么孤独。他也很聪明。他简直
hangs out in a barn next to some people speaking French and learns French in a couple days
or, like, finds a suitcase of philosophy and, like, you know, reads it and then is into philosophy.
He's really great guy. But he's so lonely. So I thought, okay, fine, a really lonely,
like unbearably lonely,
wonderful guy is trying to get another monster
because no one else will be with him to be with him,
wants someone to dig someone up from a grave
and make someone like him.
在一些说法语的人旁边的一座谷仓里晃荡，几天内就学会了法语，或者，找到了一箱哲学书，你知道的，读了之后就迷上了哲学。他是个非常棒的家伙。但他太孤独了。所以我想，好吧，一个极其孤独、难以忍受地孤独、绝妙的家伙，正试图再找一个怪物来陪伴他，因为没有其他人会陪他，他想要找人从坟墓里挖出一个和自己一样的人。
In a way, it's fair enough.
But what about her?
You know, what about the person who was dead
and didn't ask to be brought back to life?
And maybe she didn't want to marry you.
You know, maybe she doesn't get a lot of sense.
in the matter.
And I thought that puzzle, which is not addressed in the movie,
从某种意义上说，这很公平。但她呢？你知道的，那个死去且没有要求复活的人呢？也许她不想嫁给你。你知道的，也许在这件事上她并没有太多发言权。我想这个谜题在电影中并没有得到解决，
although Elsa Lancaster definitely wakes up and says,
fuck no.
I mean, she doesn't say that.
But without saying anything, that's definitely what she communicates.
I thought that's a great puzzle, like a dramatic puzzle to start from.
And how does that...
And then what if it's also an epic love story?
What if despite this very difficult beginnings,
尽管埃尔莎·兰开斯特醒来后绝对说了一句“滚蛋”。我是说，她没说那句话。但无需言语，这绝对是她所传达的信息。我认为这是一个很好的谜题，就像一个戏剧性的谜题，可以从这里开始。这会如何发展……如果这也是一个史诗般的爱情故事呢？如果尽管有着如此艰难的开端，
they can't resist each other?
Yeah.
Really cool.
Do you ever, do you ever, you were saying that you like to sort of write about things that,
I don't know what you, you sort of said, not that scare you, but things that interest you
you or things that might sort of push.
On the edge.
他们仍然无法抗拒彼此呢？对。对。真的很酷。你有没有，你有没有——你刚才说你喜欢写一些关于——我不知道你是怎么说的，你大概说过，不是那些吓到你的东西，而是那些让你感兴趣的东西，或者那些可能会推动你的东西。在边缘上。
On the edge of hope.
Yeah.
Are there ideas that you've had?
I'm curious that you've thought about writing, but you're like nervous about writing about for
certain reasons.
Are there things you go like, I don't know if I want to touch that?
I don't mean politically or anything, but just because emotionally or something.
something that you, and you don't have to answer it if it's too personal.
在希望的边缘。对。你有没有过这样的想法，我很好奇，你曾考虑过去写，但由于某些原因又对去写它感到紧张？有没有什么东西让你觉得，我不知道我是否想碰触那个？我不是指政治上的什么的，而只是因为情感上的或者其他原因。有些事情，如果太私人了，你也可以不回答。
No, I do write about those things.
Like, that's the lost daughter and that's this.
Like, I sort of do, like my daughter, my 19-year-old was joking with me because I was saying
that this one was sort of dedicated in a way to my younger daughter and that the first one
was dedicated to her.
And she was like, oh, really?
I get to have the one where I'm like, you know, the mom, like, is having such a hard time
being a mother and she gets to have the bride.
不，我确实会写这些事情。比如，《暗处的女儿》就是这样，这部也是。我确实会这样，比如我的女儿，我19岁的小女儿跟我开玩笑，因为我说这一部在某种程度上是献给我小女儿的，而第一部是献给她的。她就说，哦，真的吗？我分到的就是那个妈妈当得一团糟、觉得当母亲太难的角色，而她分到了新娘。
But I think that I think that the way I get excited and want to sit down and write and work is when I think it's a little dangerous.
Yeah.
The stuff that really lives in your deepest parts.
The scary stuff.
You've got to attack the scary stuff.
Can fill the most pages with the stuff that is a part of your deepest parts, right?
How bad.
但我觉得，当我感到有点刺激、想要坐下来写作和工作时，是因为我觉得它有点危险。对。那些真正深藏在你内心深处的东西。对。那些可怕的东西。你必须去触碰那些可怕的东西。才能用那些你内心深处的东西写满最多的纸，对吧？多糟糕啊。
And I remember actually in The Lost Daughter writing on an airplane because I used to write.
on airplanes a lot because my kids were little.
And so I would think and think and think.
And then I was, I don't know, what I was doing, press for something.
And I would just write everything I'd been thinking about it.
And I was writing one scene and I, like, looked over my shoulder because I thought,
oh, this is dangerous.
And it was just a little thing where this woman was saying,
我其实记得在拍《暗处的女儿》时，在飞机上写作，因为我以前经常在飞机上写作，因为我的孩子们还小。所以我会不停地思考、思考、再思考。然后我，我不知道，我当时在干嘛，在为什么事做宣传。然后我就会把所有想到的东西都写下来。我当时正在写一个场景，然后我，就像那样，回头看了一眼，因为我想，哦，这太危险了。而这其实只是一件小事，一个女人在说：
I hate talking to my kids on the phone.
I both love talking to my kids on the phone.
but when they were little,
sometimes it was really hard.
They just don't hit the ball back.
To say that out loud or even write it out loud on an airplane,
that was dangerous.
It's dangerous now.
我讨厌在电话里跟我孩子们说话。我既喜欢又讨厌在电话里跟孩子们说话。但当他们小的时候，有时候这真的很艰难。他们根本不接你的话。把这句话大声说出来，甚至在飞机上把它大声写下来，这太危险了。现在也一样危险。
I feel scared.
So your 19-year-old.
Oh, you're going to get a lot of pushback, Maggie, on this.
So your 19-year-old, does she have any interest in what you do?
Or is there a completely different path?
I don't think that she, at least at the moment,
and she doesn't seem like she wants to be a filmmaker,
although she makes the greatest, like, iPhone little videos
我觉得很害怕。所以你19岁的女儿。哦，玛吉，你在这件事上会遭到很多反对。所以你19岁的女儿，她对你做的事有什么兴趣吗？还是她走了一条完全不同的路？我觉得她，至少目前看来，她似乎不想成为一名电影制作人，尽管她拍出了最棒的，那种iPhone小视频。
that she edits on the phone.
Yeah.
They're so funny.
But she's been such a great sounding board for me artistically on the movie.
Like, she's seen the movie so many times.
She's been, she's such a great mind.
That's great.
So, wait, so New York, you're in New York right now?
而且她都是在手机上剪辑的。对。它们太有趣了。但在艺术上，她一直是这部电影很好的试金石。比如，她看过这部电影很多遍了。她一直是，她有着非常好的头脑。太棒了。等等，所以纽约，你现在在纽约吗？
Yeah.
And New York or L.A., and forgive me, the rest of the family's in L.A.
right?
My brother's here
and my mom is here
actually but my dad is in L.A.
Oh, I thought your mom was in L.A. too.
She used to be.
对。纽约还是洛杉矶，请原谅我，家里其他人都在洛杉矶吧？我弟弟在这里，我妈妈其实也在这里，但我爸爸在洛杉矶。哦，我以为你妈妈也在洛杉矶呢。她以前在。
She used to be okay.
And you much prefer New York, yeah?
Obviously, you live there.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
I was just in L.A., though,
and it was so nice in February,
like eating avocados.
她以前在的，好吧。你更喜欢纽约，对吧？显然，你住在那里。是的，我确实更喜欢。我之前刚去过洛杉矶，2月份的时候天气太好了，可以吃牛油果。
Yeah.
Feeling the sun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Man, I was like, I get it,
why they all do this.
It is a whole, I mean,
I've such a lust to live in New York.
But as I'm getting older and crankier and more noise sensitive and everything else,
对。感受阳光。对，对，对。天哪，当时我想，我懂了，为什么他们都想这么干。这真的是一种，我是说，我对住在纽约有着强烈的渴望。但随着我年龄越来越大，脾气越来越暴躁，对噪音也越来越敏感，诸如此类的，
I do find my little alarm going off after.
I was just there for four days seeing Shawnee.
And it was like, yeah, just a little extra space in L.A.
allows for, you know, cranky sensitivities to be taking care of a little bit more.
I mean, my goodness.
It's so compact there.
But if you had your home here, you know what I mean?
It would be different because you could.
我发现自己去过之后警惕心就上来了。我刚去那儿待了四天，去看了肖尼。然后就觉得，好吧，洛杉矶多出来的一点空间，能让人（你知道的）那些暴躁的敏感情绪得到更多照顾。我的天啊。那里太拥挤了。但如果你在这里有自己的家，你懂我的意思吗？那就不一样了，因为你可以。
I live in Brooklyn, so it's a little more outside of the craziness.
But I think that's sometimes even about people who live in Manhattan.
I go into Manhattan and I'm like, oh, my God, need to get out of here.
But I think, oh, but if my apartment were in Manhattan, I could at least just get out of here.
You know your spots and how you could sidestep.
It's so funny.
I feel, and I've been going,
and I'm sort of in the process of
我住在布鲁克林，所以离那种疯狂的生活稍微远一点。但我觉得有时候连住在曼哈顿的人也是这样。我走进曼哈顿就会想，哦，天哪，我得离开这里。但我想，哦，不过如果我的公寓在曼哈顿，我至少可以离开这里。你知道你的那些好去处，以及如何避开人群。太搞笑了。我觉得，而且我一直在去，我现在差不多正在经历，
sort of halfway moving back to New York now,
and so I'm there a lot,
and I find myself,
this is so weird,
I sleep better when I'm in New York.
I feel more at home there than I do here,
even though I've lived here full time
for just over 10 years, basically.
差不多算是一半搬回纽约了，所以我现在经常待在那儿，然后我发现自己，这太诡异了，我在纽约时睡得更好。我在那里比在这里更有家的感觉，尽管我在基本上全职住在这里已经刚满10年了。
I don't know, there's something about New York.
That's interesting, Willie.
Yeah, my, my blood pressure settles on everything.
I just feel more relaxed.
What is that about?
out? What, because the business is in LA, maybe?
No, I mean, I don't think business is everywhere. It's not really anywhere anymore.
Yeah, that's true. But I just feel like that's my, I don't know, my place. And it's,
我不知道，纽约有一种说不清的东西。这真有意思，威利。对，我的，我的血压都平稳了，什么都顺了。我只是觉得更放松了。那是怎么回事？是因为事业在洛杉矶吗，也许？不，我的意思是，我觉得事业无处不在。它现在其实已经不在任何特定地方了。对，这倒也是。但我只是觉得那是我的，我不知道，我的归属地。而且，
yeah, I just feel better. And so many of our friends are moving back to New York now, too, which is.
Maggie, where do you, what do you do outside of work that you're like, with you and the kids,
do you go to, as Will says, the Long Island? Do you travel out there?
Wait, is 19-year-old still around?
Is she going to school?
No, she's in college.
She's in college.
Not in New York.
对，我就是感觉更好。而且我们的很多朋友现在也搬回纽约了，这。玛吉，你在哪里，工作之外你都做些什么，比如说，你和孩子们，你们会像威尔说的那样去长岛吗？你们会去那边旅行吗？等等，那个19岁的女儿还在身边吗？她去上学了吗？没有，她上大学了。她上大学了。不在纽约。
No, she's...
So I just have my 13-year-old here now.
We have a house in Vermont.
Oh, nice.
Way deep, deep inside the grandfathered into the National Forest.
I will be honest with you and say that.
is really because of my husband.
不在纽约。没有，她……所以我现在身边只有13岁的小女儿。我们在佛蒙特州有一栋房子。哦，真好。非常深，非常深地隐匿在国家森林里，拥有永久产权。老实说，
The great.
The great Peter Sardgard, yeah.
For Tracy, yeah.
I love Vermont, but that's really Peter's place.
And I'm kind of always wanting to, you know, I'll go for a bit, but it's pretty hardcore.
Isolating?
It's very really in the middle of nowhere.
We were stacking wood the other day, and Peter made me laugh.
伟大的。伟大的彼得·萨斯加德，对吧。为了特雷西，对。我喜欢佛蒙特州，但那真的是彼得的地方。我其实总是想要，你知道的，我会去呆一会儿，但那里相当硬核。很孤立？真的非常荒凉。我们前几天在堆木头，彼得逗笑了我。
He was like, do you think they?
This is what our friends imagine we do when we come here.
Yeah.
Stacking wood.
Yes.
Wait, so you're out there.
Are you chopping the wood and stacking it?
I wasn't chopping it.
他说，你觉得他们？这就是我们的朋友们想象我们来这里时在做的事情。对。堆木头。是的。等等，所以你在那儿。你在劈木头并把它们堆起来吗？我没有劈。
But he chops it.
But he, like, raises bees and chickens and taps maple trees.
Oh, my God.
Has a beautiful garden.
Jason would love to pay people to do that for him.
I mean, the raising bees part, I would have to pay someone for.
Watching them do it.
Is Peter putting on the hood and everything with the bees?
但他劈。但他，比如养蜜蜂、养鸡、给枫树割口取糖浆。哦，天哪。还有一个漂亮的园子。杰森很愿意花钱请人替他干这些。我是说，养蜜蜂那部分，我得花钱请人干。看着他们干。彼得会戴上养蜂面罩和全套装备吗？
Yeah.
Although Peter sometimes is like, I don't need the hood.
I don't even need the gloves.
This guy.
I listen to a, I read this book and he did, you know,
and listen to this thing and watch these videos about how to like be zen and do it.
So the bees that come to you.
And then he gets like 10 stings on his arms, you know.
对。虽然彼得有时会说，我不需要面罩。我甚至连手套都不用。这家伙。我听过一个，我读过一本书，他做了，你知道的，听了这个东西，看了这些视频，关于如何保持禅意并做到这一点。所以蜜蜂会飞向你。然后他的胳膊就被蛰了10个包，你知道的。
Wow.
It's hot, though.
What a stud this guy is.
I'm such a good actor, and now you're telling me he's got this move, too?
A beekeeper.
You keep bees.
Yeah, but I'll tell you this, just so you don't feel bad, all of his bees in Brooklyn died.
And it was because he made a mistake.
哇。但这也挺热血的。这家伙真有型。我演戏这么好，现在你还告诉我他连这招也会？养蜂人。你养蜜蜂。对，但我得告诉你这个，免得你心里不好受，他在布鲁克林养的蜜蜂全死光了。那是因为他犯了个错误。
He made a beekeeping mistake.
And he was so upset about it.
And I was like, Peter, he were in Switzerland acting.
And then you went to another movie in London.
Right away, you were home for one week and your bees died.
like some people's only job is doing bees.
You know, like, give yourself a break.
So he was upset that his bees.
他犯了一个养蜂的错误。他为此难过极了。然后我就说，彼得，你在瑞士演戏。然后你又去了伦敦拍另一部电影。紧接着，你回家一个星期，你的蜜蜂就死了。有些人唯一的全职工作就是养蜂。你知道的，饶了你自己吧。所以他为他的蜜蜂感到难过。
Were you, did you shirk your responsibilities in babysitting the bees?
Yeah, I think I maybe did.
I think you might, you've got to be able to shoulder some of that, right?
The guys off in Switzerland.
You know, you know she had something on a piece of paper.
I'm saying, baby, all I need you to do, just water the bees for me.
I picture you guys driving
A little sticky
你有没有，你有没有逃避照顾蜜蜂的责任？对，我想我可能真的逃避了。我想你可能，你得承担起一部分责任，对吧？那家伙在瑞士呢。你知道的，你知道她在一张纸上写了些什么。我在说，宝贝，我需要你做的全部事情，就是帮我给蜜蜂浇点水。我脑海中浮现出你们开着车。画面有点滑稽。
I picture you guys driving away
Just going
Oh shit the bees
Let's just bring them
Put them in the trunk
Just bring them
Like home alone
Kevin and home alone
我脑海中浮现出你们开着车离开。嘴里喊着哦糟了蜜蜂。快把它们带上。把它们塞进后备箱。就像带上它们一样。就像《小鬼当家》里的凯文和《小鬼当家》。
So wait
I think I would go out of my mind
If I lived in the middle
Of Vermont like that
Not that it's not beautiful
And I appreciate it
And I would like to go for a little bit
Yeah because you're a city mouse
所以等等，我觉得如果我住在像那样偏僻的佛蒙特州中间，我会疯掉的。并不是说那里不美丽，我很欣赏它，而且我也愿意去待一小会儿。对，因为你是城市老鼠。
Yeah, I can't be alone with my thoughts too long.
Oh, boy.
Hang on, why?
You need to write something about them.
We got to do a celebrity version of Alone and just see how, I know.
I mean, do you think you could make it a week on your own?
Period, no.
Do you don't have to finish a sentence?
对，我无法独自一人思考太久。哦，天哪。等等，为什么？你需要写点关于它们的东西。我们得搞一期名人版的《荒野独居》，看看，我懂的。我是说，你觉得你能靠自己撑过一个星期吗？绝对不行。你不用把话说完吗？
So, well.
Yes.
If I knew it was a week, I could do it for a week.
I think.
It would be hard.
No shelter, no food.
Oh, shit.
I mean, you just have 10 items, right?
所以，好吧。是的。如果我知道这是一个星期，那我能坚持一个星期。我想是的。那会很难。没有庇护所，没有食物。哦，见鬼。我是说，你只有10件物品，对吧？
For a week.
I've only seen the last episode of Alone, which I watched last two days ago.
Yeah.
With Peter and my daughter, who were so into it.
Peter could win.
He'd start chopping wood day one.
He'd start cultivating bees.
持续一周。我只看过《荒野独居》的最后一集，那是两天前看的。对。和彼得还有我女儿一起看的，他们超级迷这个。彼得能赢。彼得绝对能赢。他第一天就会开始劈木头。他会开始养蜂。
He'd be eating honey.
But he wouldn't kill him.
He probably wouldn't kill him.
He might not kill a moose.
But I watched those videos.
This is what I'm.
I watched so many of the videos of the guys
time lapse of building shelters out of nothing.
他会有吃不完的蜂蜜。但他不会杀生。他可能不会杀生。他可能不会杀一头驼鹿。但我看了那些视频。这就是我。我看了好多那些家伙用延时摄影从无到有建造避难所的视频。
Oh, I get those too.
I get those two.
I love...
It's on your algorithm?
Yes.
Send me one so you can infect my stream.
Do you also get like Eastern European grandmas
making like huge vats of like stew?
哦，我也刷到过。我也刷到过那些。我喜欢……这上了你的算法推荐？对。发我一个，好让我的推送也被污染一下。你也会刷到那种东欧老太太制作一大锅一大锅炖菜的视频吗？
I just did.
I just started getting these videos of these Roma people
in Eastern Europe and Romania and having these parties.
And these guys are like arguing
and then these women are making this insane food
and they keep slapping each other's hands
and then they have these huge feet.
It's wild.
我刚刚刷到。我开始刷到那些东欧和罗马尼亚的罗姆人聚会的视频。这些家伙在争吵，然后女人们在做那些疯狂的食物，她们不停地互相拍打对方的手，然后他们还有巨大的一大盆食物。太疯狂了。
There's also people in China dying fabric.
If you want to get in my algorithm, I've seen those too.
Yes.
I'm fascinated by that.
I'm still getting the guys in fistfights on golf courses.
I need to flush my stream.
No, I get Karen videos.
I get just non-stop caring videos.
还有人在中国染布。如果你想进入我的算法，我也看过那些。是的。我对那个很着迷。我还在刷到高尔夫球场上大打出手的人。我得清理一下我的推送。不，我刷到的是“凯伦”视频。我不断地刷到凯伦视频。
I get tons of Karen videos and cop videos
where they argue with the cops.
Oh, yeah, about their rights First Amendment, right, guys?
I'm just filming for who?
I'm just exercising my right to film.
Yeah, you're obviously asking for trouble.
I'd love to see a mash-up with Steve Sands
arguing for his rights on the sidewalk.
我刷到了大量的凯伦视频和警察视频，他们在视频里跟警察争论。哦，对，关于他们的权利。第一修正案权利，对吧，伙计们？我只是在拍摄，为了谁？我只是在行使我拍摄的权利。对，你显然是在自找麻烦。我很想看一个混剪视频，里面是史蒂夫·桑兹在人行道上据理力争他的权利。
Wait, go back to a live for a second
because I remember this one episode
where a guy cut open a salmon or some fish
and he's like, I'll just eat that fish eggs
like caviar or whatever.
And he took a whole hand.
Do you know the episode I'm talking about?
Took a whole hand and he washed them and everything.
等等，回到荒野独居那集一会儿，因为我记得有这么一集，有个家伙切开了一条三马鱼或其他什么鱼，他说，我直接吃那鱼子，就像鱼子酱或者别的什么。然后他抓了一大把。你知道我在说哪一集吗？抓了一大把，洗都没洗就吃了。
and he got so viral, so sick.
Yeah.
I'm like, yeah, you can't just open a fish and eat their eggs.
Jason does that before.
Jason, three days before at a ward show, eats that just so.
Yeah, got to drop the water weight somehow.
Just a random fish.
Yeah. There was this one where the guy opened up a fish and there was a little tiny
然后他病毒感染，病得超重。对。我就想，是的，你不能直接剖开一条鱼就吃它们的卵。杰森以前干过这事。杰森在颁奖典礼前三天，就为了这个吃那个。对，总得想办法减掉水分吧。就随便一条鱼。对。还有一集是一个家伙剖开一条鱼，里面有一条很小的。
fish inside of it that had been digested.
And he was like, bonus, you know?
Look at that.
Two for one.
No way.
I've got to go deep with alone.
I've only seen one.
Yeah.
里面有一条已经被消化掉的小鱼。然后他说，赚到了，你知道吗？你看这个。买一送一。不可能。我得深入研究一下《荒野独居》。我只看过一集。对。
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
So if you're not in Vermont,
if you're in the city and you're not working
and you're not in post
and you're not acting,
but you're, what are you doing?
What's the thing that you're doing
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。所以如果你不在佛蒙特州，如果你在城里，又没有在工作，也没有在做后期，没有在演戏，但你，你在干什么？你正在做的事情是。
that is your like, not even guilty pleasure,
your pleasure.
How do you dumb it down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's so funny, though,
I've been in post or shooting or prep for so long.
Like, what have I been doing?
I know you've got to something.
那件甚至算不上是你的罪恶快感，而是纯粹的快乐。你都怎么打发时间？对，对，对。不过真搞笑，我做后期、拍摄或者前期筹备已经这么久了。天哪，我到底在干什么？我知道你肯定有在做点什么。
Even now, even now when you're in Post and Prep,
where you have five minutes or Tim is to do something
that's for you that you like to do
that's like a little mini break.
Even wordal counts.
Oh, I love those.
I love when they tell me I'm a genius,
even if I cheat, you know?
即使是现在，即使现在你正在做后期和前期筹备，哪怕你有五分钟或一点时间做点为你自己好、你喜欢做的事，就像一个小小的休息。哪怕玩一下Wordle也算。哦，我太喜欢那个了。我喜欢当他们告诉我我是个天才的时候，哪怕我作弊了，你知道吗？
Like, you go look at the, you're...
How smart are you?
Or like the news quiz.
I don't have that one.
How up-to-date are you with this week's news?
You take one of those little quids?
They have the history one of the New York Times, too,
where you can, it gives you a bunch of events
就像，你去查看，你是……你有多聪明？或者像是新闻问答。我没有那个。你对本周新闻的了解有多实时？你会做那些小测试吗？《纽约时报》也有历史类的测试，你可以，它会给你一堆事件。
and you have to place them on the timeline
of when they occurred.
Oh, that's cool.
It's cool.
It's good on that.
It's really good.
I want to do that.
Maggie, do you do all the New York Times games?
然后你必须把它们按发生的时间顺序排列在时间轴上。哦，那太酷了。很酷。他在那方面很厉害。真的很厉害。我也想做那个。玛吉，你玩《纽约时报》的所有游戏吗？
Yes, when I was cutting.
When I was cutting, I would basically be sitting behind my editor.
For Tracy, you mean cutting the film?
Yeah.
I'm editing the film.
Sitting behind my...
One incredible editor you had.
My incredible editor, Dylan Titchner.
是的，当我剪辑的时候。当我剪辑的时候，我基本上就坐在剪辑师后面。为了特雷西，你是说剪辑电影？对。我在剪辑电影。坐在我的……你曾有过一个非常棒的剪辑师。我伟大的剪辑师，迪伦·蒂奇纳。
Yeah, cut boogie nights and there will be blood.
and Zero Dark 30.
Amazing.
And you had Larry Scher as a DP.
I mean, God, damn.
I love the way you said that, by the way.
Just as you were talking about all the filmmakers on the film,
which is the props and the DP.
对，剪过《不羁夜》和《血色将至》。还有《猎杀本·拉登》。太棒了。而且你还有拉里·谢尔作为摄影指导。我的天啊。顺便说一句，我太喜欢你刚才那种说法了。就在你谈到电影里的所有电影工作者时，也就是道具和摄影指导。
And I don't think that people understand it maybe for Tracy, too,
that making a film, everybody on, everybody who has these great jobs,
you see the actors.
But there are all these filmmakers there who are part of the process,
who all have such important jobs,
who are so valuable to the filmmaking.
process. Well, and I just want to say, actually, because we were talking about the acting,
and obviously I've been an actor, but what I haven't been is a cinematographer. And, you know,
我觉得人们可能对特雷西也是这样，拍电影时，每个人，每一个拥有这些了不起工作的人，你只看到了演员。但现场有所有这些电影人，他们都是这个过程的一部分，每个人都有如此重要的工作，对电影制作来说是如此宝贵。过程。嗯，我只想说，其实，因为我们之前在谈论表演，显然我当过演员，但我没当过的是摄影师。而且，你知道的，
I learned a lot about aspect ratio and lensing on The Lost Daughter, but the truth is, and now I am
understanding who Tracy is, you know, on a little movie, you have no money. And so you can't afford
even to rent a lot of different lenses. So in the Lost
I thought or we maybe had five lenses, maybe.
And so with those five lenses, I learned a lot.
Then I go, as Jason Z were saying, to this totally different scope.
And I have cranes, techno cranes, shooting for IMAX, which is a very particular thing,
which is not just a movie that will play an IMAX, but a movie that's designed to change aspect ratio,
我在《暗处的女儿》中学到了很多关于画幅比例和镜头的知识，但事实是，现在我开始理解特雷西是谁了，你知道的，在一部小成本电影里，你根本没有钱。所以你甚至租不起很多不同的镜头。所以在《暗处的女儿》中，我们可能只有五个镜头，也许吧。所以通过那五个镜头，我学到了很多。然后我去了，正如杰森Z所说的那样，去到了一个完全不同的体量。我有摇臂，巨型摇臂，用IMAX摄影机拍摄，这是一件非常特殊的事情，它不仅仅是一部会在IMAX上映的电影，而是一部旨在改变画幅比例的电影。
like to grow vertically for an IMAX audience.
I didn't even know really what IMAX.
was when I started.
And Larry Cher, who's my cinematographer,
I felt like I came in to this movie
with a really clear idea of what I wanted to say
and in a lot of ways also how I wanted to say it even visually.
But I don't know, I felt like I took a masterclass with him.
比如为了IMAX观众纵向延展。我刚开始的时候甚至不知道IMAX是什么。而拉里·谢尔，我的摄影指导，我觉得我带着对我想表达的内容以及在很大程度上甚至在视觉上如何表达的清晰想法来到这部电影。但不知为什么，我觉得我跟他上了一堂大师课。
And I do feel like I finished the movie speaking a language
that I didn't speak when I started the movie,
which is maybe part of what was terrible.
Like, if you have to learn, if you're, if you know, like I was saying about actually even watching good acting, like you'd rather watch someone learn something for real on screen instead of fake like they're learning it, even if they fake it very well. I was actually learning as I was working, which was incredible, like so exhilarating, but also.
And his, did you guys, did you guys jump on his shot deck is such an incredible asset for folks?
You know, to like, you can do.
he's cultivated all of these images from all these films
that you, a quick reference point for you,
而且我确实觉得，拍完这部电影时，我学会了一种在开拍前不会的语言，这可能也是那种可怕体验的一部分。就像如果你必须去学——如果你知道的话——就像我刚才说的，甚至包括看好的表演，比起假装在学，你宁愿看某人在银幕上真正学会某样东西，哪怕他们假装得非常高明。我其实是一边工作一边学习，这太不可思议了，既让人极其振奋，又……还有他的……你们有没有、你们有没有看过他的 Shot Deck？那对大家来说简直是个太棒的宝库了？你知道的，你可以去……他收集了所有这些来自各个电影的影像，能为你提供一个快速的参考点，
as you guys were devising the look of the film,
did you guys spend some time on shot day?
Well, like, if we, say we're saying,
okay, there's big, you know,
the movie has almost like a Bonnie and Clyde aspect of lovers on the run, you know,
and there's a lot of stuff in a car,
and we were talking about different ways of shooting in the car,
and we were, for example, say,
在你们构思这部电影的视觉风格时，你们有花时间看 Shot Deck 吗？嗯，比如，如果我们说，好，这部电影几乎有点像《雌雄大盗》（Bonnie and Clyde）那种亡命鸳鸯的感觉，你知道的，里面有很多在车里的戏，我们在讨论在车里拍摄的不同方法，比方说，我们在讨论……
talking about Thelman Louise, Ridley Scott,
lots of long lenses, totally different way of shooting than we were shooting
because they were actually in that location,
shooting probably with an array of cameras,
both far away on really long lenses and then close around the car,
different than the way we did it.
But I loved the aesthetic of that movie.
I found I really loved, I really love long lensing.
比如雷德利·斯科特（Ridley Scott）的《末路狂花》（Thelma & Louise），用了大量长焦镜头，这跟我们的拍摄方式完全不同，因为他们当时是在那个实景拍摄，可能用了一组摄像机，既有远处非常长焦的镜头，也有靠近车子的镜头，跟我们拍的方式不一样。但我很喜欢那部电影的美学。我发现我真的很喜欢，我真的很喜欢长焦镜头。
My editor was joking with me that I should be a birdwatcher.
And then what about designing just the overall world of it too
With your production designer Karen Murphy
What an incredible talent she is too
Like was it how did you
Did you did you did you start
At a place because world building like
It's like filling a blank page as a writer I would imagine
我的剪辑师还跟我开玩笑说我应该去当个观鸟者。那么，仅仅是去设计整个世界呢？还有你的美术指导凯伦·墨菲（Karen Murphy），她也是个多么不可思议的天才啊！就像……你是怎么……你有没有、有没有、有没有从某个地方开始？因为世界构建就像……作为一个作家，我想象这就好像在一张白纸上填空一样。
It can it can be anything
And how did you where did you start
What sort of aesthetic did you start in was it was there like a book or photography or something
Or did she bring ideas or?
The movie is set in 1936, which was somewhat random.
Like I originally said it when I was writing just post-Civil War because so many people had died.
This is a movie about people coming back from the dead.
So I was kind of thinking about like when were the times when the veil between the living and the dead felt the thinnest.
它可以是任何东西，然后你……你是从哪里开始的？你从什么样的美学风格开始的？是有某本书、某种摄影作品之类的吗？还是她带来了灵感？这部电影设定在 1936 年，这其实有点随机。我最初在写作时的设定是南北战争刚结束之后，因为有太多人死了。这是一部关于死而复生的电影。所以当时我有点在想，生与死之间的面纱感觉最薄弱的时期是什么时候。
So I was thinking about post-Civil War.
So many people died.
So many children died in childbirth.
And there was this job then I had been learning about for something else of a spiritualist,
which was almost always a woman.
And it was like as ubiquitous as a therapist was someone who spoke to the dead for you.
And so I started out setting it then because I thought that was kind of an interesting time to just be dealing with people brought back from the dead.
And then I realized that Frankenstein, my Frank, I don't call him Frankenstein's monster.
所以我在想南北战争之后。那么多人死去。那么多孩子在出生时夭折。当时有这样一种职业，我是在了解其他事情时听说的——灵媒，几乎总是女性。这就像现在的心理治疗师一样随处可见，就是那种替你和死者对话的人。所以我一开始把时间定在那个时期，因为我觉得处理那些死而复生的人是一个挺有趣的时间背景。后来我意识到，弗兰肯斯坦——我的弗兰——我从来不叫他“弗兰肯斯坦的怪物”，
because he would never call himself that, you know?
So Frank was so lonely that maybe his only, like his primary relationship was with a movie star
who didn't know about him, of course, but that he could go sit in a theater and watch this movie star.
And also in a dark movie theater, his ugly face, you know, his scarred up face wouldn't be so, you know, scary to people.
So then I thought, okay, I have to set it in a time when there are movies.
and it shifted to 1936.
Also because the movies then are so much about fantasy.
And my movie is actually a lot about kind of breaking down the fantasy
因为他绝不会这么叫自己，你知道吗？所以弗兰太孤独了，可能他唯一的、也就是他最主要的精神寄托是一个电影明星，当然这个明星并不认识他，但他可以去电影院坐着看这个电影明星。而且在黑暗的电影院里，他丑陋的脸——你知道的，他那布满疤痕的脸——就不会对人们那么……你知道的，那么吓人了。所以后来我想，好吧，我必须把故事设定在一个有电影的时代，于是就转移到了 1936 年。也是因为那个时期的电影非常具有奇幻色彩。而我的电影其实在很大程度上是关于打破这种奇幻，
and what does a real love affair look like?
And what does a real man look like, woman look,
what is the reality versus the fantasy?
But still, 1936, which I think is beautiful.
But it was never really 1936.
It was always 1936 sort of by way of 1981 downtown New York.
Really?
By way of like right now.
真正的恋爱关系是什么样的？真正的男人是什么样的，女人是什么样的，现实与奇幻的区别在哪里？但无论如何，那是 1936 年，我觉得它很美。但它其实从来都不是真正的 1936 年。它一直都是借由 1981 年纽约市中心的方式呈现的 1936 年。真的吗？就像是现在的视角。
So if that's the directive for Karen, you know, that's a tough one.
It's something that you haven't seen before.
Yeah, but that's cool, though.
I love that idea.
So it sort of blends, it blends today's aesthetic with 81's aesthetic with 1936.
Yeah, kind of.
I mean, it is technically 1936, but it's a different world.
as you say world building,
所以如果这是给凯伦的指导，你知道的，这可真够难的。这是你以前没见过的东西。对，但那也很酷，不过。我很喜欢这个想法。所以它有点融合，融合了当下的美学、81年的美学和 1936 年的美学。对，差不多吧。我的意思是，从技术上讲它是 1936 年，但这是一个不同的世界，正如你所说的世界构建，
which is actually something I'm really interested in.
That term, which I had actually never heard before,
before I went to work on this movie,
which at least in my mind really refers to VFX, visual effects.
And something usually completely non-existent, right?
Like superhero stuff.
Like Lord of the Rings or whatever.
This isn't, you're saying.
这其实是我非常感兴趣的一个概念。这个词我在参与这部电影之前其实从来没听说过，它至少在我的概念里，确实是指视觉特效（VFX）。而且通常是一些完全不存在的东西，对吧？比如超级英雄题材。比如《指环王》之类。而这并不是，你是说——
There's some definite, tangible, relatable, recognizable elements.
But, I mean, here's something I've been thinking a lot about.
so few women have gotten a chance to get our hands on some of these tools.
Yeah.
Like shooting for IMAX with a changing aspect ratio, like world building.
I mean, there are some, there are.
But just not very many.
And I somehow feel like the way that it's been done before
这里面有一些确定的、有形的、能引起共鸣的和可识别的元素。但是，我的意思是，这是我一直在深入思考的一个问题：极少有女性有机会接触到其中一些工具。是的。比如用 IMAX 改变画幅比例来拍摄，就像世界构建一样。我的意思是，确实有一些，有那么一些。但就是数量非常少。不知为什么，我觉得以往那种做法……
is in a language that doesn't totally resonate with me.
So, you know, world building could mean we're shooting underneath like that, what would it be?
The West Side Highway up in New York has like an overpass if you're up on 125th Street with beautiful, beautiful like arches.
We shot there.
But if you look to the right, in reality, there's like a big ad for whatever, something from now and the rest of the highway and all this modern stuff.
So you can create whatever you want in the rest of that frame.
And it was interesting because when we first started working on that frame,
it was like a celebration of VFX.
所用的语言并不能完全与我产生共鸣。所以，你知道的，世界构建可能意味着我们在类似这样的地方拍摄——那会是哪里？纽约的上西区高速公路（West Side Highway）在 125 街附近有一个高架桥，上面有非常非常漂亮的拱门。我们在那里拍的。但如果你往右看，现实中有一个巨大的广告，可能是现在的某种东西，还有高速公路的其他部分以及所有这些现代化的东西。所以你可以在那个画面的其余部分创造任何你想要的东西。这很有趣，因为当我们刚开始处理那个画面时，那感觉就像是对视觉特效的一种庆祝。
It was like we were pan over to show the whole world
and look what we did with our VFX.
And that's just not, I don't like that.
Right, right, right.
I'm like, I just want to be in the movie.
I want to be in the world.
I don't need to show you how expensive the VFX were.
You know, I want to, I have a different, I'm really interested in world building.
就好像我们要把镜头摇过去展示整个世界，看我们用视觉特效做出了什么。我就是不喜欢这样，我真的不喜欢。对，对，对。我觉得，我只想呆在电影里。我想融入这个世界。我不需要向你展示视觉特效有多贵。你知道的，我想……我有不同的看法，我对世界构建非常感兴趣。
I'm really interested in that idea.
I really think probably the next thing I do will incorporate that, some kind of imaginary
world.
That's great.
I love that.
But with all the things I've learned from this one.
Sure.
Isn't it kind of, I would say this earlier, isn't it kind of like designing a house like you
我对这个概念真的很感兴趣。我真的觉得我接下来的作品很可能会融入这一点，某种虚构的世界。那太棒了。我很喜欢。但要带上我从这部中学到的一切。当然。这难道不有点……我刚才想说的是，这难道不有点像设计房子吗？就像你
get like the architect and the interior designer and the project manager and the contractor?
That's all I wanted to say.
Next question.
Or a party.
We used to think of it as a party.
like a great dinner party, you know,
where someone else is doing the flowers and the, you know,
请了建筑师、室内设计师、项目经理和承包商？我本来只想说这些。下一个问题。或者像办派对。或者办派对。我们以前把它当成一个派对来看待。就像一个棒极了的晚宴，你知道的，别人负责准备鲜花和……
and I just invite people and maybe seat them and that kind of thing.
Yeah.
Everybody's got a placard.
Oh, sorry, Sean.
Did you want to take a snack break?
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I got an apple slice.
I mean, just sort of drop in a kind of a non-secutor and then just pop an apple in your mouth.
而我只管邀请大家，可能给他们安排座位之类的。对。每个人都有名牌。哦，抱歉，肖恩。你想吃点心休息一下吗？对不起。是的，我拿了一片苹果。我的意思是，就是突然插进一句毫不相干的话，然后往嘴里塞一块苹果。
Right.
What do you think the fuck do you think is going on to your man?
I didn't think.
We're taking up Maggie's time.
You just wait five more minutes you could go get your snack on.
Yeah.
I didn't have anything else to follow up with.
对。你觉得这他妈到底是怎么回事，老兄？我没想。我们在占用麦姬的时间。我们在占用麦姬的时间。你再等五分钟就能去吃你的点心了。对。我没有什么别的话题要跟进了。
So I thought it was safe to take an apple slice.
I like that idea, though, Maggie, you said about, like,
it's never spoken to you before and nobody's ever done in this way.
And I do like that idea of like there's got to be sort of more to it
than just flexing a sort of a muscle,
which does seem to probably be in because it's been dominated.
by men and maybe I'm wrong about that,
but there's something cool about that,
所以我才觉得拿一片苹果是安全的。不过我很喜欢这个想法，麦姬，你刚才说的，比如它以前从来没跟你产生过共鸣，而且从来没人用这种方式做过。我确实很喜欢那种想法，就是这件事一定还有更深层的意义，而不仅仅是秀肌肉，这种情况可能确实存在，因为它一直由男性主宰……也许我对这一点看法有误，但这里面有些很酷的东西，
like just bringing a new perspective to it,
that it can be much deeper than that somehow.
Do you know what I mean?
Well, like, if you have a different...
Again, I'm just being simplistic about it, but maybe...
I don't mean to be overly simplistic about it either.
I just, I do think if you have a different experience in the world,
you're going to make different movies, you know?
就像是为它带来一种全新的视角，它可以比那深刻得多，你知道我的意思吗？嗯，就像，如果你有不同的……再说一次，我把问题简单化了，但也许……我也不是故意把它说得过于简单。我只是，我确实认为如果你在世上有不同的经历，你就会拍出不同的电影，你知道的？
Yeah.
And obviously, gender isn't...
Or race or ethnicity.
I mean, those aren't the only things that change your...
your experience, but they are one thing.
And I guess I, well, well, when I actually started using IMAX and changing aspect ratios and doing it, so I learned about it.
I also, my editor that we were just praising, who was just incredible, it was Dylan Titchener and Larry Cher, both were kind of in each ear really teaching me so much about those tools.
But when I imagined it, what came out was different than how IMAX has been used before.
对。而且显然，性别并不是……或者是种族或族裔。我的意思是，这些并不是改变你……你经历的唯一因素，但它们确实是因素之一。我想我……好吧，当我真正开始使用 IMAX、改变画幅比例并进行拍摄时，我了解到了这些。同时，我们刚才赞赏的那位出色的剪辑师——迪伦·蒂奇纳（Dylan Titchener）和拉里·谢尔（Larry Sher）——都在我耳边教给我很多关于这些工具的知识。但当我构想它时，呈现出来的结果与以往 IMAX 的使用方式有所不同。
And I think that's cool.
I think that's like, you know, I feel proud of that.
Let me ask you this.
Did the film turn out the way you had imagined and hoped that it would?
Because there's so many people that contribute, it inevitably is going.
And as you said, you provide this environment of, yes, please contribute, bring your uniqueness.
So did it end up?
And J.B.
我觉得这很酷。我觉得这就像是，你知道的，我为此感到骄傲。我问你个问题：这部电影最终呈现出来的样子，符合你当初的想象和期望吗？因为有那么多人的贡献，它难免会……正如你所说，你创造了一个环境，鼓励大家去贡献、去展现你的独特性。那么它最终的结果是……还有 J.B.
But also, she has a front row seat to watching it evolve and change.
Right.
And the unapologetic position of controlling the way that it comes out to the extent that you can.
And like, how much did you let yourself allow it to be the film it was kind of becoming?
And like, so like what's the, I guess the question is, sorry for the long one again, but like, what's the percentage
that it maintained
the version that you thought
and hoped that it would be?
但同时，她也有机会近距离观察它的演变和改变。没错。并且坚定不移地在力所能及的范围内掌控最终呈现的方式。那么，在多大程度上，你允许它顺其自然地变成它正在成为的那部电影？所以，我觉得问题是——再次为我冗长的问题道歉——那就是，它保持了你当初想象和期望的那种版本的百分比是多少？
Percentage in math is maybe like not my language.
Come on, robot.
Let me think.
The movie has a very specific tone.
I could always hear
the very unusual tone of the movie.
in my head.
百分比这种数学概念可能不太适合我。得了吧，机器人。让我想想。让我想想。这部电影有一种非常独特的基调。我一直能在脑海中听到这部电影那种非常不同寻常的基调。
I could feel when we fell off the tightrope,
for example, always I could.
So that has remained.
I think really when we were shooting,
I was collecting all these beautiful things.
I definitely had in some ways the movie in my head.
Yeah.
And I was sort of building something as we were shooting.
我总是能感觉到我们什么时候从走钢丝的状态上掉下来。这种感觉一直都在。所以这一点保留了下来。我觉得在拍摄的时候，我确实在收集所有这些美好的东西。在某些方面，我脑海中确实有了这部电影的雏形。对。而且我在拍摄的同时也在构建一些东西。
But the cutting, I would.
say is where it really changed.
Right.
And I think in some ways I...
It was really about letting things fall away.
Letting the movie be what I had always wanted it to be,
which was kind of like a roller coaster ride.
Like, strap in and you can't get off until it's over.
但剪辑阶段，我要说，才是它真正发生改变的地方。没错。我觉得在某种程度上，我……这真的关乎学会放手。让电影成为我一直以来想要的样子，也就是有点像坐过山车。系好安全带，在结束之前你都下不去。
Right.
There's not...
I wanted it to be like a laser beam.
Like fast and hot.
And just realizing, oh, this is weighing me down or I love this and what this brings out, but I got to let it go.
And even my really wise, you know, collaborators like Dylan, letting me take the time I needed to know.
I would say, don't fuck with that scene.
No, I don't want to hear it.
对。没有……我希望它像激光束一样。又快又热。然后我意识到，哦，这在拖累我，或者我很喜欢这个以及它所带来的效果，但我必须放手。甚至是我那些非常明智的合作伙伴，比如迪伦，也允许我花时间去弄清楚我需要知道的东西。我会说：“别动那场戏！不，我不想听。我爱那场戏，别动它！”然后最终我还是放手了。
I love that scene.
Don't fuck with it.
And then eventually letting me.
letting it go.
Because it wasn't,
probably for a bunch of different reasons
with different things you had to let go of,
because ultimately it either was not as good as the rest
因为它可能出于各种各样的原因，包含了很多你不得不割舍的东西，因为归根结底，它要么没有你拥有的其他部分那么好，要么就是对那束“激光”没有什么实质帮助。对，没错，我觉得我在剪辑自己的两部电影时，基本上就是删掉了所有不够真正精彩的东西。我只是，你知道的，而且大多数时候，我认为只要我们没拍出真正棒的东西，我就不会停机。
of the stuff that you had
or that it was sort of not serving the laser beam.
Yeah, no, I think I pretty much just took out
in both my movies when I cut them,
let's just take out everything that isn't really great.
Like I just, you know,
and most of the time I didn't stop shooting
until we had something that was great, I think.
但我们还是把那些东西删掉吧。接下来困难的部分，显然，就是割舍掉某些东西，或者比如我脑海中想象的那场戏——它已经不在电影里了，所以很难再去讨论它。但我觉得它加深了所有东西的意境。它把一切都带到了另一个层面。
But let's just get rid of that stuff.
Then the hard thing, obviously,
is like getting rid of something that,
or like for instance, the scene that I'm imagining,
which is no longer in the movie,
so it's hard to talk about it.
But I felt it just deepened everything.
It just took things down to like another level.
而且，你知道的，迪伦的观点……其实迪伦并不是一个人。我记得听过别人关于剧本反馈的一个绝妙观点，她说如果五个人对你说你看起来醉了，也许你该躺下歇会儿了。你知道的，当你不断收到同样的反馈时，
And, you know, Dylan's argument,
and actually Dylan was not alone.
And I remember hearing this great,
note from someone about
getting notes on a screenplay where she said
if five people tell you you seem drunk,
maybe you should lie down.
You know, when you just keep getting the same note
一次又一次，你不得不接受现实，心想：好吧，好吧。但事实上，迪伦的观点是，现在情节太复杂了。这让电影变得太沉重了。让它轻盈地起飞吧。所以也许那个桥段可以留到下一部电影再用。对，对。留着吧。我喜欢这样。
over and over again, you have to go like, okay, okay.
But in fact, Dylan's argument was
it's too complicated now.
It's made it too heavy.
Like, let it lift off.
And so maybe that's for another movie.
Yeah, yeah. Save it.
I love it this.
我们比你大几岁。但我真的很喜欢这个年纪，没有什么比不断地……你会觉得，我越来越发现自己在学习新东西，而且我真的很享受这种学习的过程，同时也真正开始接受自己其实知道得那么少，
We've got a couple of years.
on you. But I do love at this age,
there's nothing better than constantly
you're like, I find more and more
that I'm learning stuff and I'm really
enjoying learning stuff and also
really sort of
coming to peace with how little I do know
或者我以前自以为知道的东西其实那么有限。我现在觉得这样去探索要兴奋得多。是的，当然。嗯，是的，你变得足够聪明，能意识到自己可能并没有那么聪明。对。对。没错。对。而且当别人能够指导你某件事时，那种感觉太棒了。感觉太好了。
or how little what I thought
I knew. And I find it so much more exciting now to go like
Yeah, for sure. Well, yeah, you get smart enough
to realize how not bright
you might be. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. And how great
feels when someone else is able to guide you in something.
It feels so good.
我生活中的每一天都在想：我不知道那个词是什么意思。你在说什么？我不知道我要去哪儿。对，dictionary.com（在线词典）就在我 iPhone 的主屏幕上。真的吗？哦，我一周肯定要点开好几次。我太喜欢这个了。等等，麦姬，你今天剩下的时间打算干嘛？
Every day in my life, I'm like, I don't know what that word means.
What is you, what are you talking about?
I don't know where I'm going.
Yeah, dictionary.com is on the front page of my iPhone.
Is it really?
Oh, I hit it a few times a week, for sure.
I love that.
Wait, Maggie, what are you doing for the rest of the day?
对。告诉他们你很忙。告诉他们你很忙。告诉他们你很忙。我太忙了。我太忙了。我就在拐角处。离你危险地近。我们可以去吃个纸杯蛋糕，随便你想吃什么。我想去看《呼啸山庄》（Wuthering Heights）。
Yeah.
Tell them you're busy. Tell them you're busy. Tell them you're busy.
I'm so busy. I'm so busy.
I'm just around the corner.
Dangerous close to you.
We could get like a, we could get a cupcake, whatever.
you want to get.
I want to go see Wuthering Heights.
哦，对。我明天去看。我迫不及待了。对，我真的很好奇。我迫不及待想看你的电影。我知道，我等不及了。3月6号，可能已经上映了。我们不知道这具体是怎么运作的，
Oh, yeah.
I'll see it tomorrow.
I can't wait.
Yeah, I'm really curious.
I can't wait to see your movie.
I know, I can't wait.
March 6, it may be already out.
We don't know how this works,
但我们真的很激动能看到《新娘》（The Bride）。麦姬，能邀请你来做客真是一种享受。而且我还想看你的下一部、下一部、下一部、下一部作品。继续加油！是的，你正在拍呢。看起来太棒了。太精彩了。谢谢，太好了。
but we are really excited to see the bride.
Maggie, such a treat to have you on it.
And then I want to see the next one and the next one and the next one and the next one.
Keep jamming.
Yeah, you're just doing it.
It looks so good.
Amazing stuff.
Thanks, good.
替我向彼得问好。请替我向杰克问好。我会的。这是一次非常棒的谈话。谢谢你，麦姬。对，谢谢你来。很高兴见到你。回头在镇上见，麦姬。
Say hi to Peter.
Say hi to Jake, please.
I will.
This was such a nice talk.
Thank you, Maggie.
Yeah, thank you for doing that.
Great to see you.
I'll see around town, Maggie.
噢，不。肖恩，我们要……我要去看你的戏剧。那出戏。那出戏。那出戏。谢谢。再见。
Uh-oh.
Sean, we are.
I'm going to come see your play.
Let's play.
Thank you.
Bye.
再见，麦姬。再见，各位。再见。谢谢，麦姬。再见。再见。哦，那太令人兴奋了。确实如此。
Bye, Maggie.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Thanks, Maggie.
Oh, that's very exciting.
It is.
威利，那里的嘉宾真是太棒了。我太兴奋想看她的电影了。说真的，还有她未来要拍的所有作品，她看起来真的非常开心。我知道。我的意思是，她在所有作品里的表现都太棒了。多辉煌的演艺生涯啊。我知道。你会想：什么？
Great, great guests there, Willie.
I'm so excited to see her film.
And truly, all the rest that she's going to do,
she seems to just really happy.
I know.
I mean, just so.
good in everything. What a massive acting career.
I know. You're like, what?
抱歉，你刚才说什么，肖恩？抱歉。你为什么不能吃？你是那个正要说话、并且有自制力等着吃下一口的人。你本可以不把它放进嘴里的。一定很好吃。那是什么？只是个苹果。那只是个苹果。他刚刚发现了水果。他刚刚发现了……所以我确实想放弃。这能让讨厌的坏血病远离。我知道。我的意思是，她演过那么多好电影。
Sorry, what'd you say, Sean?
Sorry.
Why couldn't you take it? You were the one who's about to say something and you had the
control to wait on taking the bite. You could have not put it in.
It must be good. What is it? It's just an apple. It's just an apple.
He just discovered fruit. He's just discovered. So I do want to give up.
It keeps that darn scurvy away. I know.
I mean, she's been in so.
演过那么多好电影。她有着如此辉煌的演艺生涯。对。她完成了这次转型，而且这部电影看起来体量巨大。她还写了《暗处的女儿》（The Lost Daughter），并凭《暗处的女儿》获得奥斯卡奖提名。对。这部电影看起来规模宏大。跟所有这些伟大的导演都合作过。
many good movies as an actor.
She's had this huge acting career.
Yeah.
She does this turn and this movie looks massive.
She writes the Lost Daughter, nominated for an Academy Award
for The Lost Daughter.
Yeah. And this movie looks huge.
Has worked with all these great directors.
想想她能从所有人身上学到多少东西，可以去芜存菁，汲取精华。我知道。我们得把我们的演员头像寄给她。我知道。对。我多年前在一部低成本电影里和她演过一场戏，20 年前。她还没给你打电话吗？
Think about all the ones that she's been able to learn from,
to cherry pick from, too.
I know.
We got to send her our head shots.
Yeah.
I did a scene with her in a movie and a low-budget movie years ago, 20 years ago.
And she hasn't called you yet.
她没提这事。没有。我也不想提。一起合作过。她真是个天才。我太为《新娘》感到兴奋了，我也太为你们俩感到兴奋了。哦，对。
She didn't bring it up.
No.
I didn't want to bring it up either.
see together.
She's such a talent.
I'm so excited for The Bride,
and I'm so excited for you guys.
Oh, yeah.
她没提这事。对。我也不想提。一起合作。她真是个天才。我太期待《新娘》这部电影了，也为你们感到高兴。哦，是的。
Well, I feel like you guys have a bright future.
Thank you.
Thanks for having us today.
It's been so much fun to have some fans on.
Have you had any questions you forgot to ask us.
You've got our email.
嗯，我觉得你们前途无量。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢今天邀请我们。能有粉丝上节目真的太有趣了。你们有什么忘记问我们的问题吗？你们有我们的邮箱。
Yeah.
You can do follow-ups.
We'll do a follow-up and let you guys have a listen before we put it out.
Oh, great.
There's a couple of things I'm a little nervous about that I'd love to get another listen to.
Sure.
So.
Of course.
对。你们可以进行后续沟通。我们会做一个后续跟进，在发布前让你们听一下。哦，太好了。有几件事我有点紧张，我很想再听一遍。当然。当然。
Yeah.
But you know what?
Even if you say something wrong, I think that people are willing to let by God be beautiful.
Oh, incredible.
Cue the music, boom.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic.
and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barbico.
对。但你知道吗？即使你说了错话，我也认为人们愿意既往不咎。哦，太不可思议了。音乐起，轰。Smartless。Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴尔比科100%有机且手工打造。
Smart. Bless.
Smartless。